PTSD was a diagnosis that my generation
first created in order to remind the VA
to take care of veterans and to really
say to the VA
these guys are messed up because of
Vietnam and initially people said all
these guys were always messed up it must
be some other thing and the way that we
organize the diagnosis was a routing
issue of memory around if you remember
have flashbacks to witnessing people
getting killed
to the horror stuff that you saw in the
war that is not really the primary issue
that people came in with the issue of
people came in with was that they had a
very hard time getting along with other
people not blowing up at people becoming
scared and frozen having no feelings for
their kids feeling numb with their
girlfriends and general problems with
engagements as other human beings and
then getting triggered and becoming very
angry and very upset a very out of sort
and the the memory issue is also an
issue but that really is not what people
suffer most from it's really it's about
having difficulty feeling alive in the
presence feeling engaged feeling a sense
of pleasure of joy of even exuberance at
the right moments of just feeling like
boy it's good to be alive and in the
years since that time we have understood
a lot about what happens in the brain
that interferes with the capacity to
feel alive in the present the primary
symptoms are becoming upset becoming
triggered their particular sounds smells
images bring back states in which people
act again as if they're being
traumatized what happens in kids is it's
all so much memory issues but becoming
upset becoming angry being assaulted
being oppositional not trusting people
unable to concentrate to pay attention
to
engaged in anything and particularly
when you termed as a kid kids are very
egocentric and they think that the
universe is all about them that just
what it's like to be a kid and so if
terrible things happen to you you feel
like this is happening to you because
you are a terrible person so you this
becomes part of your identity I'm a
person who makes bad things happen and
I'm also a person who other people
cannot possibly care for because people
who were supposed to take care of me are
not taking care of me and so kids
develop something more like what we call
development the term a disorder in which
they invades very many areas of
functioning that doesn't mean that
adults who get tom tests may not also
have those feelings oftentimes
traumatized adults also feel ashamed
blaming himself what happened to them
when they get vapes you say I must have
done something wrong to make this happen
to me and so the issue of shame and
blame is also a very big issue for
adults something like three-quarters of
the US population experiences traumatic
events and may actually be triggered by
particular things if you grow up with an
alcoholic parents the likelihood that
you will have certain too many triggers
have certain fears of intimacy certain
tightness about getting out of control
just like that parents bent out of
control is quite common and in fact you
know one out of five American women have
been sexually molested at some point or
another
one out of four Americans have been
quite severely beaten by that caregivers
so these are common things these are
common things in the general population
and so most of us either have been
painted by their brush ourselves or no
people in our environments to whom that
has happened and we are living with the
consequences thereof and the reason why
I wrote this book actually is to not
only draw people's attention to what we
know but also to edit our attention to
the fact that we can do something about
it
and that we have learned a great deal
about how to intervene and help people
to come back to life after you get
traumatized you feel defective you feel
there's something wrong with you and you
hope that people won't notice and you
also don't believe that anybody can help
you and finding help in fact it's not
always that easy how do you know when
relationship keep failing when you fall
in love with somebody and on the third
date you blow up or you become
frightened or you find something with
that person and it bugs the hell out of
you your sense of compassion to yourself
and other people gosh aren't at the
window so be you couldn't come very
intolerant of other people he can come
very intolerant of yourself and so you
live in an intolerant environment and
your kids don't dare to talk to you you
see them becoming frightened you see
them walk out their room when you see
you sit there you turn on the television
you scream at people not to bother you
and this reactivity to people this being
bugged by people this inability to
tolerate other points of view this
inability to see that other people may
look at the world differently than you
do
is a pretty good hallmark that you have
something to work on and that you need
to actually learn to notice yourself and
to notice but goes all inside of you
that makes you so chronically angry and
irritated so ain't gonna irritate
irritation is very important piece the
other thing is and those were the
symptoms I talked about that we first
saw in Vietnam veterans and that
continues to be the big thing in child
abuse survivors car accident victims
soldiers etc etc is that feeling of not
being able to engage that life doesn't
mean very much that my joy is gone and
then it's very easy to say I've always
been like that
and then for me it becomes very
important to help people to viscerally
remember to be a member of that football
team in school or to play your French
horn in the bands or to make love for
the first time or something that at one
point can create joy and no longer it
now no longer means anything to you
and when those feelings have stopped
that means that something is frozen
inside of you and then it's time to deal
with that in order to unplug the the
river of life basically